Tổng thủ Mỹ đồ đoán trăm ngày 12 tháng người khẳng định nước này muốn dút trương quốc chưa không phải gây tổn hại.
Thế hiện sọc biệu hà dại, chỉ vài ngày xơ khi đây rồi, áp thêm bức hợi qua một chăm phần trăm đối với nền kinh tế lên thứ 2 thế giới.
Chế mạng sợ hội sư sổ sổng, ông Trumpet, Mỹ muốn dút trương quốc không phải gây tổn hại.
Đồng thời cho biết thêm, cho tịch tập cận mình đang kính không muốn nước mình dời và suy thoại.
Cũng trong ngày 12 tháng người pháp biểu chức bà dưới trên chi khóng lực bài tử estran, ông Trump căng gợi ông
tập cực mình nhà lãnh đạo thông mình và cứng gián.
Ông bây tỏ ti tự dành có thể giải quyết ông thoại vàn đề thủy quan ở chủ Quốc,
bởi ông cũng muốn quan hệ giết tốt với ông tập.
Chúng đỏ trả lời phần bình trên kênh Fox News, phó tổn thủ Mỹ J. D. Bàn,
Tổn bố, tổn thống đồ đần chăm có nhiều đồn bệ hơn chủ Quốc trong các tránh chấp thương mại,
nhưng nhà đạo này sát sáng hành động một cách hợp liy nếu hai bên tình được tình nó chung.
Mọi giá, ông bàn cũng lại chứ khả năng tổn thủng trăm có thể cần nhắc quyền nêm ít
những công ty chung Quốc có linh hệ với lực lượng vũ trang chung Quốc khỏi các sản giang dạm dịch chú khó Mỹ.
Ông nếu gió tổn thủng trăm đang đề gọi mọi lựa chọn và ông rất trỏ dàng sử dết quát theo đồ lợi của Nguy.
Cũng trên phóf news, đại diện thương mại Mỹ J. Mì sơn Grejo biết đã tìm cách liên lạc với Trung Quốc
để thả lội của địa thoại sau khi bắt kinh thông báo mở giật kiểm soát sức khẩu đất hiếm,
nhưng khi ở Trung Quốc đã chỉ hoán của gọi này,
ông bị mô thống người ông trong tình bố sẽ áp mức thủy quan bổ sung giữ kinh hiệu lực tình ngày một thống
mùi mô tổn thống. Nhằm đáp trả các biệp pháp kiểm soát sức thống mới mở gọi là hôm hàng khác thường của Trung Quốc
Hói khoảng sản đất hiếm.